first Angelina so here with Maleficent
we have a a new look at the Sleeping
Beauty fable which has gone through many
many versions including obviously the
1959 Disney film but this one puts the
idea of the traditional villain center
stage and by doing so up ends the whole
idea of the of the villain was that
particularly attractive for you and all
your collaborators to take this story
which everybody knows but come at very
very very different perspective yes I
think I remember hearing that they're
gonna make gonna make a film about
Maleficent and we thought how could you
possibly make a film where the center
character curses a baby and in any way
make that viewing and and Linda
Woolverton really wanted to to back up
the story and understand how she became
evil and I think that's a really
interesting thing to do and to question
about human nature and and and there's
there's a lot there's a lot in this film
that we hope answers for people that
that love the original and loved the
christening and loved the fun of her and
and the the wickedness and and love
Aurora and and and all her loveliness
but but then also we wanted to wanted to
make it more for for modern audiences
where it it goes deeper and they're more
complex characters their relationships
more complicated and and and so we hope
it's not just a kind of a new spin but
it's also like really updated it to to
make it more meaningful and and give it
more residence to today on the back of
that question there that this idea of
the update what do you think obviously
we see Maleficent from very different
perspective in this version of the
Sleeping Beauty story
what what's different you feel about
Aurora what was new that's being
explored here what does this film allow
us to see of her yeah well I think in
the original animated version Sleeping
Beauty in that one Aurora she's very you
know she's definitely kind of a delicate
princess and loves all things and yeah
everything that you think of princess is
and kind of all those characteristics
she she definitely has but in ours
she still is that way and she loves
everyone and it's very open and she's
not afraid of Maleficent when she meets
her witch that kind of terrifies Melissa
Boniface she's like everyone's normally
so scared of me but Aurora and if she
hasn't learned that you're not you're
not she hasn't learned to be scared of
things that look odd or you know
creatures that have horns and and it's
nice for Aurora and this one she has
more depth and obviously there are a lot
of secrets there that are kept from her
you know she thinks both of her parents
are dead and she lives kind of very
isolated in this cottage with her three
faerie auntie's and so she doesn't
really know much about you know outside
of the forest and it's nice that I could
bring you know more layers to her and
and and have more strength than just
kind of the pretty pretty princess you
know that's in in the original Sleeping
Beauty find out what for me engineer
despite the the new perspective on the
villain presumably it's still incredibly
fun to play a compellingly wicked
character like this it was so much fun
yeah she's it was hard at first I was
actually quite quite afraid to do it
because I thought it was the first one
was done so perfectly you know I thought
she was so cool when I was young she was
so elegant and powerful and and such a
great voice and I and I don't I as an as
an actress I I do film I don't do
theater so I don't actually have that
voice and I am not used to that kind of
performing and and she not only had to
have this kind of big voice but you also
have to just there's no halfway when you
have horns and big you know she's
everything about her I think I had to to
embrace my my bizarre and my silliness
and and and with yes it's a it's a you
know I think it is a beautiful story and
it has a lot of depth to it but we got a
little crazy and we had a lot of fun and
I thought I hope that that resonates and
I hope that people really are
entertained by it we really did this I
certainly for this performance I wanted
to entertain and I hope we did
childhood sweet fairy things which bones
did you like especially which ones did
you hate which figures did you laugh
entail did you play it school a part in
a fairy tale
and which one and now as a matter of six
how do you handle gonna get this I prom
I wasn't as into fairy tales when I was
when I was little and I think it could
also be you know I was I was of the
generation of the of the earlier Disney
films were at that time the princess is
you know the many of the girl the female
characters with the exception of the
Maleficent's you know we're not we're
not little girls that I admired that the
princesses
we're not characters I looked up to her
identified with I think that's very
different now for my girls and then the
more recent films my kids I read them
there's this tashi is this story that
they love and he comes in a series have
this it's too much to explain but anyway
Akashi and it's great but I but I
usually make up stories for my kids I
don't I I like to tell them stories
every night and I just make up any kind
of crazy thing and like to involve them
as characters and and and like fairy
tales you try to you try to not the side
of the fairy tale I don't like is this
idea that there are these happy endings
or that there's just good and evil and
things are perfect I I like to I think
there's when there's a good story for
children it has a good sense of a moral
tale and and I think that's that's what
I try to teach my kids and and what we
tried to do with this film as a giant
did you fantasize about the background
of maleficents already doesn't know
she's one of your favorite film
from from the beginning from all Disney
movies she was I was always curious
about her and I and like can't tell you
how much fun it was it was like being a
kid again when I got the script and it
was like unwrapping a mystery of where D
of all came from and the and who she
really was and much more than I expected
Linda Woolverton did did something
really special with this much more than
I expected but yes I think I think all
kids are curious so they're drawn
they're drawn to not the bad guy but
they're drawn to things that are dark
and I think it's not just it's it's not
just a simply a desire to you know be
wicked I think we I think there are
things that frighten us in life and and
we want to especially children they want
to understand so they can they can take
it on or they want to understand so so
it frightens them less do you think and
this is the first of many roles for
Vivian you're Joe Terra and we'll say
and do any of your other children show
any signs of becoming out after this and
the only reason we never have intended
and we still don't to put our children
in film and and and encourage them to be
actors I'm encourage them to be happy
and whatever they wish to be but the the
reason that we ended up needing to put
Vivian in the film is because there it
was a character when it's when Aurora is
five and she has to as she said not see
me as a demon and and all little kids
that came to visit set crew members
would bring their children and they
would see me and they would be terrified
they would cry or they would freeze and
and they they could certainly couldn't
do a scene with me so I didn't it
actually was genuinely out of necessity
that it had to be Vivian so we could
have a good scene but I don't I don't
know it was a it's not it's
it's still funny to us you know like
anybody it's our little girls so we see
her and she's you know she's just silly
and sweet and the idea that she's in a
movie is still kind of funny to her mom
and dad
Angelina when you're playing a character
like this can you shake her off or did
you go home and scare the family and L
what was it like acting opposite such a
terrifying character or is she like in
real life no she's not but I do think
that no one else could um could have
played Maleficent I mean I there's also
you know for me at least before I had
met Angelina I mean you hear the name
you know Angelina Jolie you know it's
like that name and then I remember
meeting her for the first time and we
were Pinewood Studios and it was kind of
that day I didn't we were doing
rehearsals and I didn't know that I was
gonna specifically meet her then I
didn't know if she was here yet but then
kind of went around like oh she's here
she's here type thing and then I turned
the corner and there she was and she's
you know no horns or anything she is
just normal clothes and but right away
she kind of became flesh you know she
was like the name kind of went away and
it's just like Angelina you know and
people on set or like Angie and you know
so um right away she gave me a giant hug
and she said oh we're gonna have so much
fun working together and she shook my
shoulders and I remember that and yeah
so it was amazing not not terrifying but
when I did see her in the costume for
the first time I wasn't scared I was
just I was more excited but you know she
had those contact lenses in and she
definitely didn't look like herself
I have to ask my family I thought I did
I thought I came home lovely you know
the interesting thing about it is as
much as she's she's she's a villain and
she's dark and she's considered mean and
she was I was very playful as her so it
is it is a film where it's not to me
playing a you know at such a heavy role
that I come home and my children have to
feel the weight of a performance and
this kind of darkness I I came home very
silly and and making it you know they
they my children loved Maleficent's
voice so they always make me do it at
home and walk around and so so I think I
think it actually brought out a real the
child in me to be a part of this kind of
film so I I think I was fun after
becoming the world famous villain
experiencing her complexity please tell
me for he was a person is there anything
in her behavior in her character that
you might envy or maybe admire her for
well there is there is you haven't seen
the film but there is a lot more to her
she she is actually somebody I I did in
the end like I think I would I envy you
know it's interesting is I think for all
of us in this room you know for
everybody watching her we all there's
there's a there's a side of us that
would like to be completely free and use
our voice to the fullest and have as big
a laugh as possible and just really in
indulge in this kind of and there's very
little opportunities in life where
you've you do this where you explore
this side of yourself and you and you
can kind of test the your power and your
voice and your strength and your and she
was that character for me I I didn't
know my voice could be that strong or I
didn't know I could have that much fun
and
so she certainly has a freedom that that
in daily life certainly I you know I
don't have most people don't have that
part of that question to you as well was
there was this anything about this role
that you felt you hadn't you hadn't got
to explore before that was particularly
new that made made it exciting for you
how well
Sleeping Beauty she I mean she
definitely has this love of life that's
unlike you know it's it's extreme so
because it is a fairy tale so everything
is definitely you know exaggerated and
you know you do see that it's obvious
that there's a light in a dark and that
Aurora's definitely kind of the light
and the smile of it and I do envy you
know her ability to kind of love
everything and be so curious about
things and and be okay with asking
questions cuz I think with me I I wonder
about a lot but I don't think I ask
enough questions about them and with her
she's she's very open and kind of self
confident in a way where she let's kind
of go for it and and she definitely
Badgers Maleficent with some some
questions which I think I would be
intimidated to if I was in her place Oh
what the event was last night um it was
it was lovely I'd never been there and
it was very unusual for us usually you
have a premiering you you show a film
and and it's very it's very traditional
it was actually it was beautifully done
it was nice to be focusing on the
creation of a film you know the the
costumes and the design and the we met
some children from the hospital who were
just lovely and fun and inspiring and it
was lovely to have them there and so I
was just know I'm a really really lovely
evening I had a really nice time in
spite of how scary
until a Disney movie and it is something
that you can take off your children to
go and see and I just wondered have your
children in the past express an
interesting thing in the films that mom
and dad have made and have you been had
to be selective in what you let them see
and when you let them see it
yes very the older ones recently some
mr. and mrs. Smith and I think they
thought that was the funniest thing
they'd ever seen that because of course
watching your parents fight as spies as
could've some strange child fantasy so
yes they have started to they're not you
know they're not as excited about it
which is kind of great they find it
sometimes it's fun my littlest one Knox
he's it's you know he sees Tomb Raider
and he thinks mommy can do all those
things and it's but this one is I think
I'm maybe the most excited about because
this is really one we can all we can all
see and I think they're all really gonna
like Disney Villains are quite loved by
the gay community how do you feel now
about being forever being a inspiration
to drag queens I would be thrilled if
it's embraced by the drag queens I I
think we both we all share a love of
this kind of costume I'm with them Algie
feel you're missing out
if you had to choose the song to
lip-synch for your life what would it be
a song to lip-synch lip-sync to Korean
song so we're good to be a queen song I
just couldn't figure I couldn't pick one
at this moment but it would definitely
be Freddie Mercury
I wonder where acting now fits in with
your priorities given that you've got
directing as well you're getting into
and also your work for the UN and
prevent sexual violence it's it's going
to be taking more of a backseat um I've
had a wonderful career and I'm very
happy to have all the opportunities I've
had to tell stories and work for as long
as I have and I will do I'm not I'm sure
there'll be a few more films but I'm
happy I'm able to be selective and have
fun with characters like this and but I
would like to focus more on writing and
directing and and and above all I would
like to do more focus more on my own my
work with the UN and with PSV I and and
if I can just say I do hope everybody in
June June 10th to the 13th is the
conference on sexual violence and and
it's an open event and I hope everybody
comes we have so far seen only the
visual sides of the films and it was
great so have you taken anything from
this in Syria I'm always I'm always want
to go so I would love to I'm I always
try to go
I will try yeah I love it there and I
love the festival I think it's really
it's one of the best festivals and did I
take anything home I do have some horns
at home
that's to put that question - did you
take anything I don't I don't have
anything but I think I don't know
they're all on display right now my
costume is limping did you draw on
anybody from real life when it came to
play in this role were you thinking
about anybody that we know from public
life when you were when you came to
portray this character I didn't I I
really did study the the the classic
animated because I thought that actress
it's such a such a wonderful her voice
was so extraordinary and I thought the
original design was amazing so but but I
also listened to a lot of tapes of
theater actresses British theater
actresses and tried to just learn from
them and they're they're you know we as
Americans are but we don't have such a
such a gift with I think with the way
with language and and and so I tried to
I tried to study that but no one
purchase person in particular an actress
no he'll put that to you as well but
what was your route to finding your your
British accent in this film well I had
an amazing um had a dialect coach that
was with me and yeah we should we tried
to figure it out I did a film where I
had to have a 60s it was in the sixties
East London accent so it was very
different from this one I was like oh
this one's we tried to find the right
you know princess voice you know it
can't be too soft and gushy so you know
she has to have some points thank you
Maleficent is a very well known
character but with this film it sort of
fills in the blanks on that kind of
protective is very interesting looking
at some of the other characters you've
played if you had a film to
those bikes which time - whether it
being white it's a great question just
God I'm suddenly trying to remember
things I've done maybe you can help us
anybody has anybody things this is very
character either one of us have played
that you feel is not complete or would
be
does anybody have a song mr. and mrs.
Smith yes salt yes say I'll take them
all mister and missus yes I feel like I
lived out the rest of that one it's
going well question both you ladies and
especially you Angelina you're really
entrenched in the film industry
producing directing and acting I wonder
how you both feel about them illegal
downloading and piracy and obviously
this film like all films and music will
definitely be subjected to it if it
helps it comes as it looks like it deals
about to be struck in the UK between the
entertainment industry and Internet
service providers that there'll be no
sort of punitive measures for people who
are offended offenders and illegal
downloaders they'll just be sent a
letter saying I'm doing an educational
letter so nothing really strong against
these people and obviously it affects
the industry massively it does yes I
don't I don't know if I'm the best
person quite technical but maybe danger
it is well I mean I just you know in
general you you as artists our job is
more we want to entertain as many people
as possible when I get stories out so
you know if but but but it is a business
it is an industry and I and I and you
would hope that people wouldn't do
something that would make it more
difficult to be able to make films and
and do films and have but you also want
your films to to reach people and I
don't so I don't know I don't I don't
know enough about the recent situation
to be able to really give you a great
answer
and the people of your age you because
lots of people do illegal download yeah
I um yeah I don't know much about it but
I I know it feels like you know they
should you know it's if it you know
they're doing it illegally and if it's
hurting that you know of other people or
any other businesses it seems like it it
sounds wrong yeah you do want law and
you want law and order you know at the
same time you you you hope people would
be able to you know afford to and and
have the access to all the art and
culture that they want and and keep it
affordable to them so maybe that's part
of the answer and making it possible for
people to I seen the entertainment
industry that a piracy you know it might
you know could cause the music industry
to collapse and possibly film in TV it
yeah I mean obviously then I mean that's
you know it there is there is it's it's
illegal so I don't really think there's
there's I think that's what we're trying
to understand what the question is
something illegal or legal yes it is you
know in some movie is a short time you
mentioned earlier the sir princesses of
Disney and days gone by I just wanted
to view we you conscious of having this
sort of female role model for a new
generation of children and how did you
approach your characters with that in
mind I think seven minutes probably you
you've probably done the most to change
to change it changed the princess really
no backstory on her you know I mean
there is but she they need to have new
she needs to have more added layers in
maker just have a little bit more
substance cuz you know she just frolics
around a lot of the other film and sleep
so and in this one I definitely sleep
but there I definitely have more scenes
and Linda wrote those scenes where I
actually you know get to do more and
also it's I kind of discovered this me
and Linda were talking that when I meet
the prince it's the first time that
Aurora has ever seen a boy in her entire
life so she looks at him like kind of
like what is this thing and I'm so that
you know she definitely gave me kind of
added little notes that I could use
because I don't think that that part of
the story you know she in the animated
movie Aurora obviously meets the prince
in that one it's kind of love at first
sight but you don't get you know that
little note of that it's the first time
she's ever seen a guy in her life so
just the little things I'll you know
come together to to make her you know a
little extra this is always a
reimagining at one of Disney's classics
there's so many great Disney movies out
there if you could reimagine any one any
character what would it be if we could
reimagine it the other Disney movie that
you could take on and really explore a
character in it like you've done in this
movie what would it be I loved I loved
Dumbo Dumbo is one of
it really is one of the best yeah do you
have do you have any idea of what needs
Laurie yeah I know well we could you
know you could do it live with baby
elephant she is I think you say that's
pretty great note in which to end which
as well as a producer running out the
back of the band ready ready to get that
one moving but Angelina do you have
platinum no I mean I'd say Dumbo Dumbo
is interesting I was always fast me with
the mother who is locked up for being
mad maybe that's a very dark version of
Dumbo but you could go with that one
you